hello it's me and my god
i'm absolutely thrilled to finally be
hosting
this show adele hosted a much
anticipated saturday night live episode
and looked incredible as she took the
studio at h
stage for the first time as host the
singer was hilarious
and even joked about her weight loss and
i know i look really really different
since you last saw me but actually
because of all the coved restrictions
and the travel bans
i had to travel light and only bring
half of me and this is the half that i
challenge
adele also revealed her biggest worry of
the night
i always get very nervous on live tv but
tonight especially so
because i swear a lot like a lot a lot
and because i'm british i tend to skip
right over all those medium ones and go
straight to the worst ones
cue to this clip of her accidentally
cussing on live tv
during a concert a few years ago this is
the best
moment yeah and looks like
things haven't changed keenan's all in
where we at
uh getting pretty full adele
this is just from when you said hi to me
backstage
oh wow all right sorry the singer used
her monologue to address
why she was host and not performing i
know there's been a lot of chatter about
me just being the host i've seen all of
it like why isn't she the musical guest
and stuff like that and there's a couple
of reasons my album's not finished
and i'm also too scared to do both i'd
rather just put on some wigs and this is
all mine by the way
have a glass of wine or six and just see
what happens while she may not have been
the musical guest
the snl host still gave fans what they
wanted
[Music]
adele brought her musical talents to the
bachelor mansion
the singer played herself in the sketch
in which she was a contestant on the
latest season of the abc hit show
hi i'm adele atkins i'm 32. you may know
me for being the singer adele
i'm here because i've had a lot of
heartbreak in my life first at 19 and
then
sort of famously at 21 and then even
more famously at 25.
but i have a really good feeling about
being k it's only night one you know
i can already tell he's gonna be the
next love of my life
adele broke out into her iconic songs
when things didn't go quite her way
like this one hey can i steal him for a
sec
there's a fire starting in my heart
[Music]
after interrupting one of ben's dates
she's saying hello but with a little
twist
she's back i can see her in the bushes
right behind us
[Music]
ultimately the bachelor thought she was
doing the most and sent her home
but adele couldn't leave without singing
just one last time
sometimes it lasts in love but sometimes
it
hurts insane
[Applause]
sometimes but sometimes
thank you everyone catch me next week on
love island